über die korona situation und das
entfallen der masken pflicht in teilen
des landes kann ich nun sprechen mit
dario schrammen er ist generalsekretär
der bundesschülerkonferenz und ich
begrüße ihn vor seiner schule in
bergisch gladbach bei köln guten morgen
herr schramm
guten morgen hallo ja bevor wir auf die
unterschiede in den einzelnen
bundesländern eingehender schrammt würde
ich zuerst gerne wissen wie ist denn bei
ihnen in bergisch gladbach jetzt
sozusagen die masken situation was ist
erlaubt und was nicht
da wir weiterhin die massen pflicht ja
hier in ganz nordrhein-westfalen
bedeutet die maske muss im gebäude immer
noch getragen werden auch am platz
draußen auf dem schulgelände kann man
dann mit genügend abstand die maske
abziehen aber weiterhin gilt eben die
masten pflicht im unterricht und daran
haben sich auch die meisten schülerinnen
und schüler gewöhnt jetzt entfällt ja
diese masken pflicht beispielsweise in
bayern jedenfalls im unterricht was
sagen sie denn als vertreter der
schülerinnen und schüler dazu begrüßen
sie diese maßnahme
wir müssen einfach sehen dass es da
unterschiedliche meinungen aufzugeben
also ich bin weder der meinung dass ich
sagen würde wir sollten die maske über
wegfallen lassen andererseits bin ich
aber auch der meinung wir sollten schon
darüber nachdenken wo kann sie wegfallen
bei in bayern hat sich zum beispiel die
haben der schülervertretung sehr darüber
gefreut im saarland wo die massen kriegt
schon etwas länger weggefallen ist da
sagt die landesschülervertretung eben
auch na ja wir wissen eben nicht wie
kann das mit dem infektion
infektionsschutz gut gehen von daher ist
jeder so einerseits die sorgen
andererseits natürlich auch der wunsch
etwas wieder kann man auch freiraum um
im gesicht zu haben es ist eine
schwierige debatte und die sollte vor
allem nicht politisch sondern
wissenschaftlich geführt werden ja
freiraum im gesicht ist ein gutes
stichwort das führt uns sozusagen zu den
psychologischen und psychischen kosten
dieser pandemie gerade für kinder und
jugendliche daraufhin weiß ganz aktuell
dass das un-kinderhilfswerk hin also es
gibt massive auswirkungen für junge
menschen wie stellt sich das aus ihrer
sicht da vielleicht auch aus ihrer ganz
persönlichen sicht was hat das in den
letzten anderthalb jahren mit den
kindern und jugendlichen gemacht
wir müssen sehen wir hatten mehrere
lockt da und wir hatten viel zeit wo
kinder und jugendliche zu hause waren
sie hatten nicht die möglichkeit eben in
den sport vor allem zu geben sie hatten
nicht die möglichkeit sich mit ihren
freunden zu treffen etwas zu unternehmen
es war im endeffekt der reine druck
schule normalerweise haben wir auch das
gute dass man eben in der schule schule
sein lassen kann nach hause gehen kann
und abstand gewinnen kann schule kam
aber nach hause durch das homeschooling
bedeutet diese belastung war enorm hoch
gerade die familiären situation dazu
kommt und für mich ist ganz wichtig weil
wir ja auch immer mehr so richtung
zumindest normalität und einer pandemie
kommt diese auswirkungen sind nicht
vorbei kinder und jugendärztin wahlen
auch jetzt ganz massiv davor dass wir
jetzt sagen okay wir sind durch mit
dieser pandemie damit haben wir auch die
psychologischen probleme warum nein
alles andere ist der fall wir müssen
genau jetzt gucken wo er ist eben hilfe
benötigt wie geht denn die schule wir
gehen denn die lehrer mit dieser
situation um jetzt wo es ein bisschen
auf dem weg richtung normalität ist gibt
es da maßnahmen in der schule und weiter
gefragt fordern sie solche maßnahmen
sozusagen wie schülerinnen und schüler
nach der pandemie wieder ins normale
leben zurückgeführt werden können
absolut wir müssen schauen dass wir eben
wieder eine normalität kommen und vor
allem das ist meine große sorge auch
immer schon gewesen müssen wir oder
sollten wir nicht so tun als wäre nichts
passiert also nicht eben wieder sagen
okay wir machen jetzt weiter mit dem
einmaleins der gdc analyse die natürlich
wichtig ist sondern wir müssen hingehen
und gucken wie können wir das
aufarbeiten also wo können wir den raum
geben auch darüber zu reden was passiert
ist weil viele haben eben diese vielen
erlebnisse mit denen sie auch ja die sie
auch teilen wollen und da muss jetzt
schon und auch die lehrer gucken wie
können sie den raum finden vor allem
muss dann aber auch die länder sozusagen
gucken wie sie denn den raum überhaupt
geben können ja und der raum muss
angstfrei betretbar sein das führt uns
zu der frage herr schreiben es ist ja
noch ist es warm aber der herbst und
winter stehen ja vor der tür wie sieht
denn die situation in den klassenräumen
beispielsweise bei ihnen aus sind denn
der luftfilter mittlerweile eingebaut
worden
das thema luftfilter ist ja sinnbildlich
dafür was in der bildungspolitik in den
letzten anderthalb jahren passiert ist
wir haben ein hilfsprogramm der
bundesregierung über 200 millionen euro
davon ist zumindest mein stand kein
einziger cent abgerufen worden das liegt
an der hohen demokratischen die arbeit
die dahinter steckt das liegt an vielen
zuschüssen die von den ländern und den
kommunen kommen müssen wir haben ihn
fast keinen schulen im land wirklich
flächendeckend luftfilter es gibt ein
zehn bundesländern die sind gut
ausgestattet aber es ist eben nicht
dieses gemeinschaftliche und lassen sie
mich das vielleicht auch noch zu der
masse nicht sagen gerade da sehen wir
auch wieder dass jedes land seinen
eigenen weg geht das ist für mich schwer
nachzuvollziehen weil das corona virus
in nordrhein westfalen ist dasselbe wie
zb in bayern und da macht es schwer sind
oder ist es schwer nachzuvollziehen
warum in dem ein land die maske wegfällt
in der anderen nicht und das eben auch
auf die luftfilter bezogen da müssen wir
auf jeden fall deutlich besser werden
denn der föderalismus hat jetzt in den
letzten wochen mal wieder gezeigt dass
das wirklich sehr sehr großer
flickenteppich ist sagt dario schreiben
der vertreter der schülerinnen und
schüler aus bergisch gladbach ich sage
vielen dank dafür und einen schönen
schultag noch in bergisch gladbach
vielen dank